all right welcome everybody it's
November it's a new week we're going to
start with something really instructive
today uh last week the week before I
talked about sort of the inherent
difficulty of confronting these
conspiracy theorists or conspiracy
delusionists with the idea of I'm just
going to show them how each one of their
claims is wrong and that it's really
difficult to do this in real time I
talked about a recent Sam Harris podcast
episode where he outlines this very well
when he's asked what about having
someone like Brett Weinstein on
and arguing with him about each one of
his points related to vaccines and
Ivermectin Etc and Sam Harris very
astutely pointed out it's really easy to
start 10 small fires and if you can only
put out eight or nine of them it kind of
ends up looking like you didn't really
address this elephant in the room there
was a really good post on uh our
subreddit which mentioned this and has a
link to an interview that happened on
Friday where Bill Maher interviews Sean
Spicer and this user reflex Point
actually says uh Bill Maher versus Sean
Spicer and why fact-checking conspiracy
theorists in real time is a problem
David was recently mentioning Sam
Harris's statement about why it can be
dangerous to argue with conspiracy
theorists in a live format because if
they just start Gish Galloping a bunch
of nonsense in real time it can be
difficult to come out of it looking like
you won and Sean Spicer does a perfect
example of that when giving his reasons
to question election Integrity he'll
point to some obscure rule that changed
in some Battleground State and then
claim it suspect and Bill is supposed to
know about it and if he doesn't then
bill must be wrong and having confidence
in the election results so let's take a
look I'm going to play this two and a
half minutes uninterrupted
see if you can keep track of all the
different assertions that Sean Spicer
makes I'm keeping track and then we're
going to go through them in a moment
what about what about the election was
rigged and Trump really won is that I
think there are some serious problems
with the election here we go no Time Out
Hold on name when you look at
Pennsylvania Wisconsin Nevada the idea
that we changed Rules running up to an
election in terms of how about okay when
it was counted do you think Pennsylvania
the law signed by a Democratic governor
2019 acts 77 signed by Governor wolf
said that all ballots had to be there
was a pandemic that's why they didn't
change the law they okay there was no
time to do that so you should just never
well you would have no there wasn't
there wasn't plenty of time to pass
legislation and all of these others this
is a rabbit hole you want to go down to
avoid the question did Trump win or lose
the election I don't know well there you
go because as the world does nobody
first tell me how many votes that got
cast in legally and not according to the
system but this was litigated in every
Court's even Republicans who were in
charge of the vote came down on the side
of this election was fairly adjudicate
you yourself said right after the
election they asked you about fraud you
have said I have seen no evidence
correct I haven't but what I have seen
is a state there's a difference so
imaginary no no there is a difference
what Pennsylvania's Supreme Court did
what Wisconsin's clerks did they let
people Wisconsin does not have a
provision in their law to let people
vote early in person it has an absentee
ballot provision people set up uh tables
in parks in Madison Wisconsin and
allowed people to come without
identification in Pennsylvania they were
allowed to vote without identification
no postmark on the ballot in violation
of Acts 77 signed by a Democratic
governor in 2019 and the answer is well
then don't worry about it because it was
a pandemic what's the next thing that
you can just blow away A law is a law
until it's changed you don't get to pick
what you want to follow follow depending
on what's happening outside okay this
again this was looked at
exhaustively
what was looked at for example in
Wisconsin the Court ruled four to three
okay Sean I get it you know what you're
like you accuse me you said your piece
you said your piece I haven't looked at
this you're like that kid in school
who's right no
no who who has to do has to answer about
the book report so reads one page very
carefully that nobody else read and then
does the thing on that and then we don't
know what you're talking about you do
but we know that what I do know okay so
so that's a lot so think about all of
the different things that Bill Maher in
principle or in theory had to be ready
to refute and how difficult it is now
we've done it after the fact but just
look at how much time this is going to
take me so Sean Spicer mentions
Pennsylvania Wisconsin and Nevada and
says they change rules leading up to an
election he mentions a 2019 Pennsylvania
law signed by government Governor wolf
that says ballots have to be in by 8 pm
on Election Day he's asked did Trump win
or lose he doesn't know because he
doesn't know the results in different
states he asks how many votes were
illegally cast he says the Pennsylvania
Supreme Court and the Wisconsin clerks
changed rules and Wisconsin has no
provision to let people vote early in
person only absentee and that there were
Parks just letting people vote with no
ID Pennsylvania allowed people to vote
without ID and with no postmark on the
ballot and that violates act 77 and then
he mentions the Wisconsin Court ruled
four to three he doesn't say he doesn't
actually say what they ruled or what the
case was so look at all of this
different stuff we now have to deal with
in order to Simply say hey uh Trump lost
and that's it
on Pennsylvania Wisconsin and Nevada he
says well there were problems and he
just lists them
but he doesn't really explain what the
plot problems were in 2020 the results
were Biden 303 and Trump 235. if you
flip all three of those States Trump
gets the 270 votes he needs but that's
if you flip all three let's say Sean
Spicer is right but about two of those
three states and what he's right about
actually means that Trump won two of
those three states Biden still wins the
election in that case so even at its
face he's throwing out three states as
if Trump probably won them just to
demonstrate that in one of those Trump
actually won would be a Herculean effort
for which there's no evidence but if you
only are able to successfully
demonstrate
Trump really won two of those three
Biden still wins that election so that's
a real red herring
second rules changed leading up to the
election some states did change election
procedures without legislation but
that's no big deal we've studied this
already I already told you Rebecca green
election law professor at College of
William and Mary said it's often the
case that election statutes have gaps
that don't account for particular
situations like the pandemic so just
because a decision was made not from the
legislature it was made by the
governor's office or a Public Health
Board or whatever that's really not a
big deal Spicer asserts that it happened
as if that's a problem it's not actually
a problem it's common
many states also changed election rules
because of the pandemic blue States and
red states did it states that Trump one
did it and States Biden one did it and
big shocker these Republicans only ever
talk about the fact that states Biden
one did it North Dakota changed rules
due to the pandemic not through the
legislature leading up to the election
so did Arkansas so did Texas they all
made State changes in that way Trump won
those they don't make a peep about those
then Spicer mentions mentions a 2019
Pennsylvania law signed by Governor wolf
which says ballots have to be in by 8 pm
um it's true that Pennsylvania law did
require ballots to be in by 8 pm on
Election Day but before the 2020
election the state supreme court of
Pennsylvania extended the deadline
so ballots could be received by mail
until 5 PM on the Friday of election
week if they're either postmarked by
election day or have a missing or
illegible postmark they did a new
deadline it was dealt with the
Pennsylvania Supreme Court dealt with
that now if Sean Spicer wants to argue
the Pennsylvania Supreme Court is
illegitimate in so doing that's a
different argument but it's been dealt
with in a legal way that is accepted as
a valid way to change when absentee
ballots can be received
then Spicer says well how many votes
were illegally cast it's such a vague
question it's meaningless because his
definition of illegal might be it was
received after 8 pm on Election Day in
Pennsylvania but as I told you the state
supreme court already dealt with that so
what does he really mean by illegal
votes Wisconsin he says had no provision
to let people vote early in person only
absentee well Wisconsin didn't used to
permit early in-person voting but then
they decided to in 2021 they can do that
he says well the clerks decided the
clerks have the authority to decide that
they decided it legally and changed that
rule it's not actually a red flag the
way he says and then lastly he mentions
the Wisconsin Court ruled four to three
and he doesn't tell you what they ruled
well I looked into it the conservative
LED Wisconsin Supreme Court ruled four
to three not to throw out 220 000
ballots that the Trump campaign wanted
thrown out
Spicer mentions it look the Wisconsin
Court ruled four to three yeah but what
did they rule it was a it was a
conservative majority Supreme Court
which decided you can't just throw out
these 100 220 000 ballots
um so each of these things when you
analyze them is really nothing it's not
a Smoking Gun it's not a red flag but if
you watch the two and a half minutes I
played for you it might seem like Bill
Maher didn't really refute everything
and this is exactly the challenge that
Sam Harris has recently talked about
when asked why aren't you debating more
of these vaccine Skeptics or Ivermectin
Advocates or whatever
because they show up and they go wait a
second you didn't see the Bangladeshi
study you which showed what you know
whatever no I didn't see it oof wow you
and and you think you know what's going
on the Bangladeshi study may be
something it may not be something really
good example glad that it was posted to
our subreddit one of our sponsors is
called privacy privacy is a totally free
service that I've been using for years
privacy lets me create virtual payment
cards with one click and when I use the
virtual card the money is taken out of
my bank account you can create multiple
cards delete them freeze them set a
spending limit on them let's say I'm
signing up for a free trial and it
requires a credit card privacy will
autofill a virtual card number and then
after signing up I can delete that
virtual card so I know I'm not going to
be charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say I'm
ordering food over the phone but I left
my wallet somewhere I don't have my real
credit card on me I can use a virtual
card on my privacy mobile app but really
the best part is you're not out there
exposing your real credit card number so
you're not as susceptible to data
breaches and identity theft privacy C is
a totally free service and you'll get
five bucks to spend when you go to
privacy.com Pacman the link is right
underneath this video